this is the northern bald eagle  an iconic bird that we almost lost for  good only a few decades ago northern  bald eagles are the larger of the two  subspecies of the bald eagle  their wingspan can reach over seven feet  they are powerful flyers that soar  through the air reaching over 40 miles  per hour when gliding  they're excellent predators attacking  from above with their long and sharp  talons  by the 1960s their population was  decimated with less than 1 000 left in  the wild  chemicals from pesticides traveled up  the food chain rendering these top  predators sterile or unable to lay  healthy eggs  thankfully after massive regulations  were put in place they have made a  near-full recovery  today loss of suitable habitat is still  a threat as they are very sensitive to  human activity  this is the northern bald eagle  you